a lot of people ask us how we came up
with the idea for sausage party it all
started in 2007 at one of our business
brunch ins in a new movie idea man no
man you got any hot died no brah I got
nothing
writing movies is hard where we lose me
that hot dog talk yeah a few years later
we pitched it all over town oh it went
really well everybody wanted it bidding
war what do you mean no one wants to
make a movie about a talking hot dog do
you think it was the shorts course was
the shorts the recording process was
really easy it's really fun working with
your friends this is gonna be fun dammit
say it like a sausage not like a human
all we hear is human well that's my best
sausage well your best sucks and the
best part is through all this evidence
relating ship is stronger than ever
I'm supposed to see it a lot yeah well
oh yeah I slept with your wife I slept
with your wife
I know